[Music]
you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as
they arrive so it's time to see what's
making the headlines
with director of demos think tank polly
mckenzie and editor of nottinghamshire
live
natalie faye they'll be with us right
through until midnight i hope you know
what you've signed up for
they're still smiling so let's see
what's on the front pages of those
newspapers for you now the guardian
leads with
calls for the prime minister to isolate
after allegedly being
side by side with a staffer who tested
positive for covet
number 10 denies they came into contact
the times reports optimism from
government scientific advisors
who claim further lockdowns are unlikely
as covet cases fall
the mail calls on climate conference
minister alex sharma
to quarantine after flying to several
red list countries
ahead of cop 26. the mirror looks to
tokyo and a hall of fame
as team gb celebrates yet more success
during the games
the sun also leads on olympic success
for team gb
including laura kenney joining charlotte
du jardin
as the most decorated female british
olympian
the uk's olympic spirit is spurring the
economy according to chancellor rishi
sunak that's on the daily express
meanwhile the telegraph leads with
comments made by the archbishop of york
who questions why he thinks it's become
taboo
to be patriotic and on the front of the
ft
the fierce battle for the supermarket
chain morrisons continues
as potential buyers raise the stakes
and we're joined tonight by polly and
natalie standing by
good evening to you both uh let's start
off first off with the
times the front page there the headline
reads no more lockdowns after fall in
covid cases
an optimistic headline and one pointing
to the fact that
we do seem to be registering fewer cases
now polly
yeah i mean the numbers continue to be
positive and going in the right
i mean what scares me a little bit is i
think we
headlines this time last we said no more
school
i think we're going to have to leave you
for a second
polly um you seem to be cutting in in
and out if i can just get you to jump in
and try and sort
polly's sound out there and natalie your
thoughts
um yeah well i mean my first thought
when i saw this headline was um
i think we've seen this before haven't
we no more lockdowns
i've literally read something this
evening on another news website saying
the government has got a plan
for uh fire break lockdowns in the
autumn so we're kind of in this
no man's land again great uncertainty
obviously
it's great news from the office for
national statistics today what they're
calling the gold standard statistics
showing that there's been a good drop in
coronavirus cases hospitalizations and
deaths obviously that's
no death to good news but a drop in
death is very good news
um but i think the future is not certain
and that's for sure and they're
interviewing professor neil ferguson on
the front page of the times
um and he's been wrong about a couple of
things in the past
so who knows i think it's people have to
decide for themselves
um to whether to be cautious or not
obviously they should be cautious
i would say but you know we need to make
sure we're taking the right precautions
for your own risk level and i don't know
if we can rule out another lockdown to
be honest
after what's happened in the past yes uh
what what do you think people will make
of this
type of of headline do you think they'll
they'll give a sigh of
relief or will approach this type of
news very very cautiously
i think we can probably take it with a
pinch of salt because we have no idea
what's going to happen in the winter
and i've seen that on the front page of
the times they're saying it all depends
on whether
the nhs becomes overwhelmed in the
winter but the nhs
does very often become overwhelmed in
the winter
with just the normal flu season my local
hospital the
queen's medical center in nottingham an
absolutely excellent hospital
but it had to introduce an extra level
of alert over the past couple of years
because the strains on services there
were so great so they had a black alert
which is a new one they'd never had
before
and they've introduced that for the past
couple of years so with covid on top of
that
um i can't see how the nhs is not going
to become overwhelmed
i don't want to come on here and be a do
monger but you know i think we have to
be realistic about the facts that
cases are going to go up things might
get worse
and um as we've seen in another on of
other reports this evening
the vaccination does not necessarily
stop people passing it on as well
yeah i mean the hope is that things are
improving the article
is saying that ministers are daring to
hope that the crisis will soon be over
after the ons showed that in the final
week of last month an estimated 1 in 75
people in england had the virus
down from 1 in 65 the week before
i think we have polly back now i mean
that definitely does point to a more
positive situation
uh seemingly people seeing the light at
the end of the tunnel polly
yeah much more much more cheerful news
than we had any reason to expect i think
coming out of those lockdown measures
um i'm sure seasonality is part of this
and we all have to just i think keep our
fingers crossed that the vaccination
program
globally can help to keep numbers under
control so that we don't
see the emergence of a dangerous new
variant which could of course
uh cause real harm to the progress that
that we've made here and in
in many other countries with the kind of
more developed vaccination program
natalie take us into the guardian and
this is the
story of the prime minister refusing to
isolate
after having reportedly come into
contact with a member of staff
that has tested positive for covert
although downing street is saying that
he wasn't within uh two meters of this
this member of staff although they
traveled in the same
plane what do you make of this story
well i mean the guardian seems to be
saying something completely different to
that and they were
in very close contact together and went
through a number of functions together
um so it's just the kind of um
i don't think this is going to go away
for boris johnson at all
and um he'll probably be who probably
will be forced to isolate i mean he's
already retreated to checkers which has
been his
isolation um place before so maybe he's
getting ready for i don't know but
um i think from a normal member of the
public's point of view
it's going to be seen as one rule for
you another all for us
yet again and the confusion over who
should isolate who shouldn't isolate
why does the prime minister not have to
isolate
um we had the whole argument over alex
sharma coming out today as well he's
been jetting all over the world to red
zone countries
um you know and apparently that's highly
important and he doesn't have to isolate
but lots of other people would say their
jobs are really important to the running
of the country as well so
i think we need some clarity on the
isolation rules um and
just to hear from boris johnson why he
thinks he shouldn't have to isolate
polly do you think that this uh story is
likely to to blow up or have her downing
street uh put the lid on it
i think we're getting close enough to
august the 16th
when those of us who've had two
vaccinations won't have to self-isolate
if
pain just just take tests the the kind
of the the
argument will start to fall away i mean
the government's repeatedly said they're
not going to bring that date forward
seems to me kind of with the numbers
going in the direction that they are
that that's probably both just a
political mistake actually because
you know the when they refused that they
refused for you know what
three hours or something to self-isolate
when they were pinged
a few weeks ago and then changed their
minds when it was seen
as natalie says to be controversial and
one rule for them another rule for other
people and
so to go through this again i can
understand why the prime minister who's
trying to go about his job would feel
frustrated
and getting endlessly pinned but of
course lots of us have been through that
lots of british people will be
trying to go on holiday and finding
themselves pinged just at the moment
when they don't want to be so
i think the solution is to eliminate
hypocrisy
use this as an incentive to encourage
more people to come forward for their
vaccinations
and just move to this situation where if
you're double vaccinated
you've just got to test if you've been
close to somebody who
uh who's confirmed with covid let's have
a look at the
yorkshire post next and this is a story
about um
rural communities not being served um
sufficiently by
the nhs natalie
yeah i mean it's quite right of the
yorkshire post to highlight this there
are so many inequalities in healthcare
all around the country and rural
communities well known for being one of
those
but also inner cities um coastal areas
you know i also oversee lincolnshire
live as part of my patch and
chris witte recently published a report
saying coastal communities are really
badly affected by health inequalities as
well
i don't know how that compares to rural
communities but i think that the point
the yorkshire post is making could
probably be widened out to many areas in
the country
um that we do need better health care
for people who are isolated
you know i think people in rural
communities probably more elderly
um as they are in coastal communities so
more likely to suffer
from long-term health conditions and um
you know
it's a good point they're making i fully
agree with it but what's going to be
done about it
well that's the question isn't it we
just got time to
talk about this next story in the daily
telegraph
and it's um the archbishop of york
attacking uh what he's calling the
patronizing
london elite um that's quite a severe
attack polly why why is he doing this
why is he saying this now
it's very fashionable i think to attack
the patronizing london elite
i'm surprised he didn't say that they
were also metropolitan um
but actually he's got a point he's
talking about the fact that it is
perfectly possible to be
english to love being english to
celebrate englishness
in a way that's not about an ethnic
identity but about a civic one
that is open and modern and inclusive of
all sorts of
uh diverse different kinds of people and
and can be celebrated and he he's
criticizing those
who criticize those who feel english on
the assumption that if you feel english
you must be a sort of small-minded
racist i used to think he does have a
point
but we're actually getting to this stage
where
he's kind of ten years behind the
argument right they this was an original
point about ten years ago and
actually with if you think about what
happened during the the euros in
particular it felt like
the real coming of age of a story of
englishness that was uh
not about petty-minded small you know
small englandiness
it was just about inclusion and so he's
kind of right but i don't think the way
to
land that permanently is to start being
snarky about metropolitan elites
because the kind of point of
inclusiveness is that metropolitan
people
get to be part of englishness as well as
uh
you know rural people or people from
small towns in the north natalie do you
think we need to redefine englishness
is that what's at stake here
i'm not sure about that i think you know
i think we probably need to reclaim
englishness and
shake off the kind of things that people
feel awkward about being english
um redefine it i i don't know maybe
there's an opportunity at the moment
because none of us can go abroad really
um so we're all reading parts of the
country and this is the time
to um be proud of our country again and
rediscover it all
in nottingham we have the biggest
george's cross in the country on the
council house every single year
which looks fantastic that's done by
nottingham city council
but you always get people moaning about
it and saying this makes me feel
uncomfortable
but i think they should continue to do
it and we should just you know
go through that until we get to the
other side and realize that it's
actually fine
to be english can we just be comfortable
with it and not awkward
natalie thank you very much interesting
take there nestle and polly
thank you very much for the moment we
are going to take a break coming up the
imminent rise
in energy prices and the claim that
green energy will not cut bills for a
decade
we'll discuss that next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now the director of demos think tank
polly mckenzie and editor of
nottinghamshire live
natalie fay welcome back to you both
let's have a look at the
daily telegraph and their front page uh
and this is a story about energy bills
which we've obviously been covering
today and the fact that they're likely
to increase
substantially uh people extremely
worried
polly yeah i think this is just
such a crucially difficult time in the
run-up to
cop 26 this vital climate conference
in glasgow later in the year which is
supposed to
uh agree an international plan
for exactly how we are going to cut
carbon emissions and get to that crucial
net zero
in order to keep climate change under
control but
right at this exact moment when the
government needs to hold its nerve and
encourage
other countries to make these
potentially difficult political
commitments
around that carbon transition prices are
going up and it's
not primarily to do with the uh
green uh incentives that are built into
our energy system it's actually to do
with
fossil fuel prices as you've been as
you've been reporting
it's gonna put pressure on families it's
going to cause political problems
already we're seeing conservative mps
really really worried both about you
know the direct cost to their
constituents and that kind of the
political storytelling
is the government uh because of climate
change gonna
add on you know what more cost more
leverage into bills
there's talks about boilers uh there's
talks about heat pumps being put into
people's homes
the crucial thing we have to remember is
that we do not have high energy prices
in this country
we have high energy bills the amount we
pay per unit of electricity or gas is
relatively low compared with our
neighbors we just have really really
inefficient badly insulated homes
and that's an infrastructure investment
that can improve jobs
and actually save us money in the long
term it's just
in the long term in the long term but
the essence of the story is that
cheaper green energy won't reduce
consumer bills for at least a decade and
the average
increase is 153 pounds which is uh
substantial to very many families let's
have a look
at the daily mirror and the olympics uh
great news we're fourth in the table now
natalie yeah i mean it's absolutely
fantastic i see um the expresses leading
on it as well and saying it apparently
it's a boost to the economy how well
we're doing in the olympics i mean
i'm not really sure about that but it's
great to see it definitely
um and uh today's been called ladies day
because so many
women ended up on the podium which is
absolutely fantastic from my point of
view
but you know it's more than that it's
about inspiring the next generation to
be active
and to take up sports that they might
not have thought of i mean skateboarding
for example
i know who knew you're going to get your
skateboard out aren't you
ladies thank you both good to see you